when former russian spy alexander
litvinenko died in london in 2006 from
radioactive poisoning it shocked the
world that such an attack could happen
on british soil since then russia has
been was found responsible for his death
well with me now is alexander's widow
marina lipvinenko who is in exile living
here in london marina thanks so much for
joining us tonight on my first show i
really appreciate it um
now let's kick off with your recent
holiday you were in ukraine as i
understand it uh just in the run-up uh
to the invasion i think you left just
after the invasion you're with your
friends
what was the atmosphere like
and how are your friends
and the festival very good evening and
shall i start with a very special words
glory to ukraine
ukrainian this is very important to all
ukrainian to hear it and to all people
who support ukraine now
when i went to ukraine i know it's a
very tense
situation in a board
from sight of russia was very much uh
unexpected and unexplained and
unexpectable and everybody discussed
would be this war or not but i decided
to go 16th of february because i thought
it's a good time to to have a nice time
in the very west of ukraine what is a
very peaceful very beautiful area
and i didn't think i would be in ukraine
and i received this news war has started
in the same moment all the small town
was mobilized it was not panic it was
not history everybody tried to receive
news from their relatives in the east of
part in ukraine from kiev from kharkov
it was shocking news
and this small town expected this all
refugees immediately
and started to think how they could
accommodated them how they could bring
them to the port if they decide to
travel to poland or to another country
people wonder how could they
help refugees did they start arming
themselves did they
this was all just uh i would say people
were ready for something
worse but of course they didn't want it
but they've been
ready for this because this was a lot of
organizing of self-defense organization
when all men were ready to go to this
people went to special station to give
their blood even i went to do this so
you gave blood so everyone went to build
your blood supplies yes
yes and this was so many people it looks
like this old town was ready to give
their all blood to these soldiers to
casualties to anybody did putin
miscalculate the ukrainian people's
spirit one hundred percent i think 2014
give them to putin and to his alliance
justice's wrong message
ukrainian people soft they're not going
to fight and like in crimea just will
say welcome and would be happy to be
part of russia but it was wrong
and how are you friends now
uh it's still quite a serious but this
part is okay it's in the west so they're
it's very west and i think the areas of
conflict yet yes it's it would not leave
this is more close to slovakia border to
poland to hungary but people in kiev in
a very serious situation i have very
good friend of mine a member of a
ukrainian radha and she is she's a woman
and a young very promising politician
she's fighting with kalashnikov
and marina let's talk about your late
husband alexander sasha as
you
knew him all spoke of him um i think
we've got a wedding photo actually of
you
uh
there you are um can you see it there
marie it's on the screen yes isn't that
a lovely that's gorgeous huh um i just
want to ask you about a letter that
sasha wrote an open letter to putin two
days before he died you you know this
off your heart uh he said you may
succeed in silence in one man but the
howl of protests from around the world
mr putin will reverberate in your ears
for the rest of your life
when did sasha realize that putin was
bad for russia from very beginning
and when he stand up in 1998
against of all this corruption and
security service it was his first fight
against vladimir putin because he would
he was put to prison and spent almost
one year
and then when he escaped he published a
book blowing up russia about apartment
bombing when he openly accused of
security service to do this crime
against russian people because they want
to show putin is a strong man and he
will defend all ordinary russian people
what was not true and his second book
was just explained everything that
happened in fsb successor of kgb
and this was all his what he tried to
prevent and marina do you you obviously
have friends in russia still that you
talk to
do you think that russian people
understand what's what's going on or do
you think that because of the media uh
restrictions that they don't really know
what's happening in ukraine from your
experience of talking to people it's
it's not even restrictions it's
completely brainwashed and some people
just afraid to think about truth they
may be understood something very bad
happening in ukraine but they're afraid
to talk about this because they they
can't believe that this is really
happening they're afraid of the truth
because you need to
accept you live in the country who's
aggressor and this is very difficult and
sometimes they started to defend
putin defends
all these actions
marina do you think that the russian
people might eventually overthrow putin
or is it so repressive there that it's
it's not possible we don't know soviet
union collapsed in 1991 when nobody
believe it because it was the strongest
country
and opposition to all as a world
and now yes it's a different one but i
don't think it's as strong as it was
soviet union yes they tried to control
everybody every individual but we still
have people outside in the street which
is all processed and marina can i just
ask you as well you you've lived in in
britain you're adopted country since
2000 so over two decades now are you
happy with the way that britain has
responded to the crisis
now of course it's much better than it
did happened before and the every time
cry for this you have to do something
now it's a huge international support
and it's this united country in european
union united kingdom america and other
other countries what is very important
for putin it was always
very important to make these all
countries to work separately to divide
everywhere exactly and so now he will be
confounded or confused by the fact that
you west has united he might not have
anticipated it's another surprise for
him
do you think that we're taking enough
refugees
i don't think so and we know this
picture from carlos in paris when people
need to go back to
apply for visa
it's a shame because i saw these people
spend hours and hours to get through
ukrainian board and then go to see maybe
their relatives here in uk and i would
like to say these people don't want to
get out from ukraine they pushed from
ukraine yes and they're not looking for
better life they definitely come back
when it would be all finished so you
would like our prime minister to follow
the european union and introduce visa
waivers for the people of ukraine
absolutely because you will save these
people and they will all time grateful
for this and just finally um
do you think that
politicians here made a mistake in
welcoming russian oligarchs so warmly to
the uk in the past
of course we need to learn all mistakes
for what we did and of course uh
politicians places
uh i would say ruthless because you
should it should be checked and money
and people have been accepted here and
now we should talk about not a past we
should
talk about present and about future not
to make more mistakes